okay sure you know whatever we need to  be current we need is a hard rock and  hip look at all these new bands now they  don't have pyrotechnics there are sparks  flying on the stage it's all tame we  need to go to Coachella and yes yes and  I agree a hundred percent by the way  it's called no challenge no I I couldn't  get a cent to Coachella all right open  killer song you got it  I think this is the stuff that inspired  Kurt Cobain this is the most powerful  po2 you and your friend will ever take  [Music]  we're on a spiritual question we're at  this close to getting another shot we're  gonna focus if it kills you there are  risks you as much as her one fly cursed  until next Sunday  [Music]  [Music]  I'm in the music industry that [ __ ]  happens everyday in rock and roll  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  I'm gonna make it rain  [Music]  you